and so on the end as it was in the
beginning there are five nominated films
for Best Picture
they are Elizabeth Alison Owen Eric
Felner and Tim Bevan producers life is
beautiful Elda ferry and Gianluigi brass
key producers Saving Private Ryan Steven
Spielberg Ian Bryce mark Gordon and Gary
Levinson producers Shakespeare in Love
David Parfitt Donna gelati harvey
weinstein edward zwick and mark Norman
producers The Thin Red Line Robert
Michael Geisler John Robideau and Grant
Hill producers
and the Oscar goes to Shakespeare and
love
carpet Jonna gelati
in for mark Normand who
for original screenplay
Wow this is just fantastic thank you to
the members of the Academy we share this
award with John Madden because we
wouldn't be up here without him he made
us look real good and that there is no
director that he's a producer's dream
the other people who share this with I
think I'm forgetting them are my own
personal lucky charm is Gwyneth Paltrow
Geoffrey Rush Joseph Fiennes Judi Dench
Colin Firth Ben Affleck I saw you there
I referred Everett and David come help
me here for a minute please
well we also like to thank Universal who
with Ed and Mark started all of this and
Miramax who had the courage to finish it
our fantastic crew and who else are we
thinking I'd like to thank mark Cooper
clearly Clark and my partner in all
things bliss Barron thank you the other
guy that we really need to think though
is Harvey Weinstein who had the guts the
courage the commitment to make this
picture and get it done
this was an ensemble film and it took an
ensemble team to make it I want to thank
at Disney Michael Eisner and Joe Roth
who've given me great latitude and great
support at Universal Edgar Bronfman Ron
Meyer Stacey Nadya Bronson Chris McGuirk
at Miramax
my brilliant Meryl poster my Head of
Production who rocks the universe and
makes us look good oh man Julie
Goldstein who is the most persevering
brilliant executive producer - Bob oh
sure - Marc Gill and Marcy Granada who
are the one in - most dynamite marketing
team brother Bob I'm getting there okay
I don't know we made this movie this is
a movie about life and art and art and
life combining is called magic for me
this was a great experience a passion
for five years and nobody inspires me
more than my brother Bob who was my
partner and best friend every day my
loving wife Eve my two rotten kids Lilly
and Emma my beautiful nieces Sarah
Nicole and my mom Miriam the Mihrimah
Miramax who makes the Jewish mothers
look good
okay